la ciudad ecuatoriana de la UCI sigue
asolada por los deslizamientos de tierra
que se cobraron la vida de varias
personas y dejaron decenas de
desaparecidos Mientras estiman que el
número de víctimas siga aumentando las
operaciones de rescate continúan sin
embargo los familiares de los sepultados
tienen cada vez menos esperanzas
que me encuentre siquiera una casa o lo
que sea este
para ver si me si me cojo algo o si no
me cojo si no es que ya para vivir vida
de ellos que ya no tengo esperanzas que
se encontrará en cuerpito de ellos para
ver sepultar Nada más estamos esperando
a mi cuñado a la hija de mi cuñado Y a
mis dos bebitas que estaban enterradas
estamos en de ayer pero no se ha podido
lograr nada entonces Esperamos que ahora
pues logremos encontrarlo para hacerles
una sepultura se merecen ellos en este
panorama hay personas que temen por su
situación y por de tierra que tenemos
miedo de que se deslice otra vez y nos
quedemos sin nada algo igual no tenemos
a dónde llevar porque no hay aquí casas
de arriendo ni ni nada el lunes por la
noche el presidente Guillermo lasso que
fue abucheado a insultado cuando arribó
a la UCI prometió continuar con los
rescates y anunció trabajos de
recuperación de agua potable de las vías
de acceso y un complejo de viviendas de
auxilio para atender a Los afectados las
lluvias torrenciales destruyeron
carreteras puentes y otras
infraestructuras en un contexto donde el
mandatario declaró a principios del mes
el estado de emergencia en 14 provincias
por el clima adverso y un terremoto